enfin peut être lié sein d'un maçon
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est on ne peut jamais
être tranquille de minutes avec ce
téléphone de marins
qui me téléphonent à cette heure là
c'est toi julie bonjour si c'est
vraiment gentil de m'appeler à une heure
pareille au mi6
emmène en
quoi une mauvaise nouvelle
ce n'est pas vrai que l'on est sûr
merci je n'ai pas de temps à perdre on
n'a pas de sous marins par ea laborda
voilà il faut ranger absolument
clairement la méso amérique amérique et
dans jardin en train de cueillir
à bernie tu as à berriac oui voila voila
c'est toi qui m'a appelé li na
évidemment je suis simple dans cette
maison héééé est pourquoi
pour pour l'un mais toutes les fuites tu
vas prendre le chemin du petit bois pour
aller jusqu'aux jardins aller mais je te
dérange tant que ça mais non il n'y a
pas une seconde à perdre dans un instant
mais catastrophe
un cyclone une tornade un cataclysme une
calamité va s'abattre sur cette maison
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire tous ces
mots là elles veulent tout dire la même
chose avait et de réfuter à nous rendre
ici quoi elle lui est imputée va venir
la célèbre botaniste au plus c'est
formidable je vais lui préparer des
petits gâteaux
germain est inconscient sens trois grecs
mais mangent pourquoi je ne te dérange
pas
cette façon c'est trop tard on revoit et
c'est bon courage ral week
moi
entrer en très chère mademoiselle
foutais
mais comment se nomme cette adorable les
petits papillons 20 h albéric
mademoiselle mais attention je ne suis
pas un petit papillon vert je suis un
casimir us germait casimir germain mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut tout simplement dire que je suis
le cousin germain de casimir voilà
au mignon tous
oui bien albéric vous êtes exactement
celui que je cherche j'ai besoin d'un
assistant pour m'aider à ramasser des
feuilles d'arbres voulez vous m'aimez
assistons de la scène les braises mais
chut et oui c'est merveilleux c'est
mieux mais euh je n'y comprends pas
grand chose c'est décidé venez avec moi
jusqu'au jardin je vais tout vous
expliquer je vous suis mal je vous suis
bonjour je vais vous conter aujourd'hui
l'histoire du paysan et du diable un
jour un paysan qui avait fini son
travail aux champs s'apprêtait à rentrer
chez nuit à la nuit tombante il remarque
un soudain au milieu de sa terre un tas
de charbon embrasé et quand tout surpris
il s'en approcha vite un petit diable
noir ainsi en plein brasier on dirait
que tu es assez sur un trésor du le
paysan bien sûr répond le diable sur un
trésor qui contient plus d'or et
d'argent que tu en as vu dans toute ta
vie
le trésor est placé dans mon champ par
conséquent il m'appartient dit le paysan
il sera à toi répondit le diable si
pendant deux ans tu veux donne la moitié
de ce que ton chant produira de l'argent
j'en ai assez je désire un présent les
fruits de la terre
le paysan accepta le marché afin qu'il
n'y ait pas de contestation lors du
partage du tyne tout ce qui pousse
serein au dessus du sol serein à toi et
à moi ce qui sera dans la terre la
proposition plutôt diable mais le paysan
madray ce mad et n'avait autant de la
récolte le diable 20,1 clamé sympa mais
je ne trouva que des fusions des fans et
il ne pètent et paysans tout content des
terrains ces navets
pour une fois tu as le profit dit le
diable mais l'année prochaine
il n'en ira pas de même à toi ce qui
poussera au dessus du sol un mois ce qui
poussera en dessous cela me va répondit
le petit paysan quand vint l'époque et
semailles le paysan ne se bat plus de
navet mais dublet le grain mûri le
paysan à larouche en couple les épis et
quand le diable arrive un ne trouvera
plus que le chaume et s'en retourna
furieux dans sa cave et en haut du
rocher
voilà comment il faut tromper les
voleurs dit en riant le paysan en allant
chercher le trésor
[Musique]
a les américains je
vous présente nouvelle coup albéric
votre assistant il n'a jamais quitté la
ville avant de venir ici ne paient rien
au peuple mais si mais si d'ailleurs
mademoiselle futé m'a promis de tout
m'expliquer alors
bravo albéric je suis certaine que vous
en connaissez beaucoup plus que vous
bien voulez-vous présentation
d'expériences tout à fait d'accord
mademoiselle
je ne pars pas mademoiselle je le
partage mais pour mieux comprendre ce
que vous allez m'expliquer je fais
quelques mouvements de gymnastique
n'at-il pas dit un esprit sain dans un
corps sain le symptôme très bien je vous
ai
aimés et même pas écrit mais n'est
qu'argent fils si l'enjeu les me prépare
physiquement
et bien j'ai l'impression qu albert et
n'a pas fini de nous réserver des
surprises
le journal le journal à un monsieur
martin voilà le journal que vous m'avez
de montbert citons pas à la nage je suis
fatigué j'ai couru en plus très très
gentil tout va mais c'était pas la peine
de courir six ans ici aussi mais
pourquoi ben pour avoir plus vite ma
récompense tient une récompense pour un
journal ben c'est normal non je rends
service mais le service n'est pas
compris alors que tu espères que je vais
te venir pour boire un pour moi ah non
non non non j'ai pas soif non non non je
parle pas du pourboire mais du service
quelle jeunesse et qu'est ce qui te
ferait plaisir à bavay jeu je veux je
veux une table de ping pong avec des
raquettes rouge tac tac tac tac tac tac
coin pour un journal non premièrement il
n'est pas polie de dire je veux il vaut
mieux dire je voudrais où je
souhaiterais à bonbons mous je voudrais
c'est plus poli - ah bon alors je
voudrais s'il vous plaît des balles
aussi des pénalités balle tac tac tac
tac
weeds et balbin je voudrais en plus
attendez un cerf-volant si si si en
france en mai mais ça va me coûter très
cher enfin tout ça pour un journal que
voulez-vous un tout augmente à tout le
monde mis un peu lui chaut
montre fois n'était pas si exigeants
non c'était pour rire monsieur martin
c'était fou rire je vous ai fait marcher
je ne veux rien mais je voudrais c'est
plus correct c'est vous qui me l'avait
dit non oui bien sûr
je voudrais un bonbon de ben bongo je
voudrais tu voudrais il part en avant
j'ai racheté monjournal moi même ou
alors j'écoute à une nouvelle à la radio
on serait déjà lu ça alors tout bas tu
m'as apporté le journal d'hier pardon
pardon pardon et généreux comme vous
êtes vous vouliez pas en plus le journal
du jour non
éditorial
alors mademoiselle fit est toujours
contente de votre assistant injalbert il
est un être exceptionnel
sérieux boyle y réfléchissez revient
ce sera un bon exemple pour cette
volupté sinn je trouve que casimir est
très serviable aussi hors jeu l'héliport
mais on peut confier des missions
albéric que casimir remplirait à coup
sûr de travers à vous croyez vraiment ah
oui mais attendez qu'il revienne je lui
ai demandé de me ramasser les quelques
fois que voici une feuille de
marronniers une femme de pain
une feuille de nénuphar
une feuille de être
une feuille de chêne
et une feuilles de platanes et vous
croyez vraiment qu'il va vous trouver
tout cela j'en prends le pari julie
avant de partir il m'a demandé de tout
lui explique j'ai une confiance totale
en lui
excusez moi
allô bonjour monsieur prochaine ah non
non non oui bien sûr je vous préviendrai
au revoir messieurs vos chaînes non mais
que se passe-t-il et il n'est rien
arrivé albéric ça n'a aucun rapport
quelqu'un a emprunté la brouette de
monsieur beauchesne et il en a besoin
ça n'a rien à voir avec halle berry à
l'avoir au regard des
voilà mademoiselle futé je ne vais pas
faire mieux étant donné que je ne me
souvenais plus exactement ce que vous
m'aviez demandé j'ai amassé tout ce que
j'ai trouvé dans la forêt